the debt snowball you list your debts
smallest to largest you pay minimum
payments on everything but the little
when you attack the little one with a
vengeance
scorched Earth lifestyle sell so much
stuff the kids think they're next take
16 extra jobs we're getting out of debt
and you pay everything you stop all
investing temporarily and completely
Focus all your emotional spiritual
Financial relational energy on that
smallest debt everything goes on that
one that one's gone you take the payment
that used to be there and any other
money we can squeeze out of our budget
and we throw it at number two and when
that one's gone we take the payments
from one and two the snowball rolls over
again it picks up more snow and you
attack number three the average person
for the past 25 years that has done that
with great focused intensity gone crazy
to the point that broke friends and
relatives thought they needed counseling
they shaved their head they drank the
Kool-Aid they get out of debt in about
18 to 24 months everything but their
house